Okay. Good morning, everybody. Welcome to the last day of AACR.
Congratulations. It's been a fantastic meeting.
I hope you've enjoyed it as much as I have.
And today, we're going to have an amazing session.
I'm very excited to hear from all of the people who are speaking today on the
topic of induced proximity pharmacology, degraders, and beyond.
So we're going to start with Danette Daniels from Foghorn Therapeutics,
and the title of her talk is "Towards New Cancer Medicines with Degraders of
Chromatin." Danette.
All right. Thank you, Michelle, and it's really my honor and pleasure to
be here
speaking to you today about
the work that we've been doing actually over several years,
looking and studying trends of degraders.
So here's my disclosure information.
I am an employee and shareholder of Foghorn Therapeutics.
So just a little introduction about Foghorn and the
goals that we have.
We really have been focused on understanding
the roles of chromatin regulatory proteins and transcription factors,
both their native function in normal cells as well as their aberrant
function in disease. And
it's been a fantastic conference for the
company. We've had multiple posters as well as talks in other
sessions on these very important oncology
targets from SMARCA2 or BRM,
ARID1B, and CBP, and EP300.
So we've been taking advantage of targeting these, either with
small molecule inhibitors or
degraders to really leverage cases of synthetic
lethality within oncology or specific lineage
dependencies.
Now, why develop degraders?
As we have degrader programs for multiple of these
programs, and they are a very key and important part
of our portfolio.
I would say that most of the targets that we
have in more advanced stage programs have
really used degradation to leverage and introduce
selectivity amongst closely related paralogs, and
often paralogs that are involved in identical
complexes. So I have here, for example, paralogs
BRD7 and 9,
CBP or EP300, and then ARID1A
versus B. So you can introduce
selectivity either at the stage of binding with your degrader, or
if you have a dual binding nature, you can introduce
a selectivity through linker design as well as E3,
and ultimately degradation.
The selectivity has really enabled us
to have the efficacy and outcome that we want with
improved tolerability.
So also,
one of the main driving factors for many of our targets is
that they are not enzymes. So one way
then to go after drugging these types of targets, clearly then,
is removal via degradation. And we have many
targets, as you know. Chromatin remodelers, as well as transcription
factors, have a lot of intrinsically disordered regions, and
there's been many successful examples where targeted protein
degradation now can address these types of targets.
And lastly, degradation really
gives us optionality, both on the target that we can
drug, as well as the choice of E3 ligase binders.
And Foghorn has developed a significant toolbox
utilizing many different E3 ligases.
So I just want to do a
broader look in degraders, and
this is the first time I'm giving this type of talk.
Rather than focusing on one specific program, I really
want to share with you the learnings that we have had as we
have taken degraders, developed them across
multiple programs, and the insight and learnings we've had on
the key important features of these
degraders. So we have three
very active programs, a selective EP300 degrader,
a selective CVP degrader, and a selective ARID1B
degrader. And each one of these degraders, we would
like to apply to multiple different indications.
And when you think about a degrader needing to show activity and
robust activity to achieve efficacy across
multiple indications, you need to have
exquisite properties of that degrader.
Now, everybody in the field talks about potency.
This is often reflected in terms of DC50.
This is a measurement that you can make for a degrader, but it is a static
and
unique time measurement. Exposure, very
critical for a degrader, especially as you're thinking about going
across various different indications.
But what I want to focus on today is a parameter which
is not discussed as frequently, and that
is the degradation rate of a degrader, and the types of
degradation rates that we've been able to observe across the programs, and
how then do we use this parameter to help guide us
and inform us on the best degraders to
use.Now, just to
reorient ourselves before we start a deep dive into
degradation rate.
It's very critical you understand the native homeostasis of
your target. We measure target half-lives for each one of our
targets, and we do it in all the various cell lines and
different indications that we are considering.
And native homeostasis can vary greatly for a target.
Now, in this balance that keeps the
endogenous level of your protein, we then start
to apply degraders. And if you have a slow
and moderate degrader, what you see routinely is you
slightly tip this balance. And the result will
be a new homeostasis, which yields
a partial or some fractional amount of
loss.
What you really want, though, is this fast degrader.
This is going to tip the balance here to your complete
degradation. But we all know that there's
resynthesis and such. So we have to, in
developing degraders, really keep this balance tipped such that
it's tipped the entire time. And not just
at whatever time point measurement you choose
when you're looking for your DC50.
So
we hear and this is where I think
the field, even here at this conference, we hear, "Oh,
fast degraders are better.
Fast degraders show more reliable in vivo
PD."
Well, what does a fast degrader mean?
It's like saying potency is important, but not qualifying if
it's micromolar potency, nanomolar potency,
picomolar potency. We really wanted to
understand what does fast mean? And could
we put some quantitative numbers to fast
and do it
for every target.
So here I have a theoretical rate curve.
This is what you would expect based upon that balance of the native
homeostasis, the addition of a degrader compound,
and how it starts to impact your Dmax.
So you have this native degradation rate.
That is the rate that keeps that concentration of your target
around all of the time. You start to add your degrader, you get 10%
degradation, 25%, et cetera, until you hit this
complete or Dmax 90, Dmax 100, whatever you
want to call it, complete degradation.
And I have an experimentally measured kinetic rate curve
here for one of our CBP degraders. It's a very
potent degrader. It's starting here at nanomolar.
But you can see this exactly plays out in
cells, where we can, in a dose-dependent way,
start to see these rates that are correlating with these
specific Dmax. Well, we can then now
put this on a graph. So we started building rate versus
Dmax graphs. And this now is that same concentration
series plotted against Dmax. And you can see as you're
increasing concentration, you now can reach
up to that complete level of Dmax.
Now, we first
or my former team first described this
in 2017, this relationship between rate and
Dmax. We have how to calculate it. It's a first order decay
parameter. But what we didn't appreciate
really then
is how universal this would be. Is this a rate versus Dmax
specifically for this compound? Is it a rate versus Dmax for a
target? Is it that target in that cell line, et cetera.
And so really
building out the understanding of this
idea has really taken many years and a much broader
analysis.
And I also want to point out that every compound
has a plateau of the maximum rate that it can
obtain. And this is really baked into what we
often call in degradation, the efficiency of the compound.
So we did a large-scale study at Foghorn on
our
expansive collection of BRD9 degraders.
And
really seeing this graph for the first time was one of those moments where I
said, "Wow, what
a striking relationship we can have compound, over
compound, after compound in building this
capacity for an understanding of a rate versus
Dmax." And I want to really bring
your attention to these degradation
rates over two.
You can really make very fast
compounds that have this really
high efficiency across a series. Now, what we were able
to do in this larger scale study is define
now what we call a rate inflection point.
And this is the rate at which you are now
getting guaranteed to have a full and complete
Dmax. And we could start to bucket these rates, this
inflection, the turning point
into Dmax ranges. So 0.7 to
one was 85%. One to 1.8, you
were going to be in the 90%. And then if you were over
this rate of 1.8, you were guaranteed with that compound
always or other related compounds to always see a
complete Dmax.But
even beyond this inflection point, you could see now compounds
would really differentiate themselves in terms of efficiency.
Now, we then started to build all of these same relationships for
all of our programs. You can see the BRD9 program, we
were looking at very advanced compounds.
CVP and EP300, I put these graphs up here because we
started to include the gamut of compounds, from the very early compounds that
maybe didn't achieve complete Dmax, to the later,
really well-developed compounds that were reliably obtaining
Dmax and had in this lower
nanomolar and even picomolar potency.
And you can see this kind of relationship holds
irrespective of the target. And so we really believe it
will be an intrinsic relationship across
all targets and degrader programs.
And we can then define for each of these programs
this inflection point, and we start to call this the
cliff. We want to stay away from the cliff, this rate cliff,
because as soon as compounds drop below these rates, we
know we will start to see target recovery
happening. And we've also built these curves
for these targets in different cell lines as well.
So indeed, these inflection points do change, as I
mentioned, given the changes in native homeostasis for each target
in different cell lines.
Now, how do we quantitate it? How do we take all of these findings and
really put some numbers to it? And that was
translating these changes in rate that occur via
concentration. So now we have plotted here rate versus
concentration. We're able to calculate an AUC
for every single compound, and this is going to allow us to
compare the efficiencies of compounds,
irrespective, say, of their DC50.
And also, we started now in these
compounds to try to figure out and understand which mechanisms are
contributing to the rate.
So here's four compounds for our EP300
program with their AUCs overlaid.
And I have here in the table their
respective DC50s.
Three of these compounds you would think are nearly identical if you look strictly
at their DC50s. If you look at the western blots, also,
you would say they are nearly identical because they all completely degrade.
So they each have rates which are over this
inflection rate needed in order to obtain complete
degradation. But when you plot their AUCs against
each other, wow, they look very different in the
efficiency that they can obtain and the
concentrations at which they are sampling these
high rates. So now we can rank them additionally on the AUC
for each of them, and you can see how some
become much more interesting, say, to follow
up from a rate perspective, rather than solely thinking about the
DC50.
We then move to cellular ubiquitination assays, and we see very
nicely a matching increase in
ubiquitination of targets
for the ones which have faster rates, particularly at
lower concentrations. And this is what was
seen also back when we started these studies
almost nine years ago, is that this ubiquitination and
the signal for degradation is really driving these
faster rate in these compounds.
We also do a lot of work at Foghorn to look at ternary complexes.
Here we have biochemical ternary complexes via SPR.
It's the same series. I have the kinetic traces
for each of these across a dose response curve.
And you can see very nicely on the upper
panels that we're getting more stable, more long-lived
ternary complexes as the rate is increasing.
And this is reflected in the slower Koff rates that
we can measure by SPR.
So all of these data really
want to go back, and we ask ourselves, would we have
missed compounds if we had strictly looked by
DC50? So all of us, for many years,
judge compounds, judge other people's compounds by
DC50. But now if you take this kind of
two-dimensional look, adjust DC50, and you
overlay the rate capacity of these different
compounds.
Some of you might think this is great correlation.
I'll let you be the judge based upon your comfort with R squared
levels. But we really see that there
is indeed, as you are enhancing compounds and enhancing DC50,
a general move towards faster rate compounds.
But we see so many examples where you have the same
DC50, but very different rates. And those
maximal rates that you can obtain can be up to fivefold even
different for compounds with the same DC50.
So these are all great considerations when we're weighing
in all the variables that we think when going in
vivo is looking at how they might distinguish
themselves in terms of rate as
well.Now we want to be able
to go, as I mentioned, to use this information to help us
inform on compounds to choose to go in vivo
ultimately. So here now
we're thinking about how do we, because rate is a
parameter that changes with concentration,
we are able to measure the concentration, the PK in vivo.
What rates will we be sampling in vivo at different
concentrations? Are we at the top of our curves
for efficiency with our compound when we actually go to
dose in vivo? So I've taken the same rate versus
concentration
plot here. Now I've corrected it for the unbound
concentration plot. And this then is
applied to
PK/PD analysis where we can now
translate the concentration that we are sampling in
vivo, but map it back onto our rate curve
and see where we are at Cmax, see where we
are at C trough in terms of the rate sampling of these
compounds. And I just have two examples here with a CBP
compound, 10 mgs per kg or 3 mgs per kg.
You can see with both of these across both the Cmax and the
C trough, we're sampling that maximal kind of
efficiency of our degrader compound.
And
this is translating now into robust
loss of the CBP. So we're looking now to kind of match
and take those same Dmax versus rate
curves and now translate into
rate versus PD, in vivo PD, and try to
build those relationships.
So with this, I just want to summarize
how Foghorn has been thinking about
degraders, that we've taken not only the potency and
exposure, but now this incorporation from our large-scale
studies across multiple programs on the importance of degradation
rate.
This is event-driven pharmacology.
Rate is the event. It's capturing that kinetic event
that we are inducing. I think as we hear more
about other induced proximity modalities and the event
driven that they will have, understanding the
dynamics of those event-driven processes are going to be
very critical. And also tying that back to how those can
change with different concentration, also very important.
So yeah, that's all I had
for this and I'm happy to take any questions.
We're actually out of time for questions, but that's fine.
No questions?
Oh.
Okay, one question.
Yeah. Thanks for the great talk. I have quick questions.
So you have great in vitro rate with
Dmax.
Yes.
Does it correlate in vivo Dmax? Because you have rate of
PD in vivo. Has correlate rate of Dmax in vivo.
Yeah, so that's exactly what we're looking to build, those relationships
to understand the rates that we are sampling, that we had been able to measure
in vitro, build that relationship now with PD.
Yeah.
To try to understand.
Last question. So your rate of Dmax
is not E3 related? Like BHL,
CBL all have same data, all is
driven by targeted binding potency.
So which part, this part or that part?
Which part driven most relevant to in
vitro rate with Dmax?
So
the
rate initiated by any E3 ligase, irrespective
of the ligase, is going to drive the Dmax that you
can observe. So, that is independent.
Now, there are many mechanisms from
ternary complex cooperativity, off rates that we showed,
productive ternary complex, rate of ubiquitination, and then
the polyubiquitination that has to translate that will
help drive what that rate, what that
capacity of that compound, how it has positioned
things in order to drive the rate. And that is why every
compound has its rate plateau.
Some compounds will only go as fast as 1.5.
Other compounds can go to 10.
So,
it is that combination of all those
mechanisms which drive that ultimate rate.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thanks so much. Let's thank Danette Daniels again.
And hopefully we'll have time afterwards. People can talk to her after.
Okay, Gwen Hansen. Pleasure to introduce next Gwen
Hansen from Nurix Therapeutics. The title of her
talk is Designing Effective Degrader Therapeutics: What Early Clinical Experience
Has Taught Us.
Gwen.
Yes. Thank you. Thank you everybody for staying here till the last day.
I really appreciate the opportunity to tell a little bit of a story for one of our
programs at Nurix.
So disclosure, I am an employee of Nurix, and my legal disclosures go on and
on.
So what I wanted to talk about today, because this is a session on
pharmacology, is some of the learnings that we have generated with our lead
degrader in the clinic. Some of the things that make us really confident
that this is really a new wave of drug discovery that will change the way that we
are able to treat disease in patients.
So this slide really is meant to illustrate that there have been many major waves
of how drugs have been created and how effective drugs can be in
treating different types of either proteins or biology, small
molecules, antibody, nucleic acid therapeutics.
But we really at Nurixbelieve, and
I think the field believes, that targeted protein degradation
will be another major wave, meaning that it will really create
differentiation from some of the other small molecule drugs that have been created
before. And I think in this conference, people have seen how this has
now really expanded the concept of how bringing proteins
together through small molecules can really affect many different changes in the
cell. So I'm going to tell a story about our lead program because I think we
have advanced it far enough now that we have collected enough in
vitro and in vivo and clinical data to really understand how we can
compare degraders to inhibitors.
So that was one of our first fundamental questions, really trying to
decide whether there are new drug effects that you
can get through small molecules, even with very well-credentialed
proteins that are well-established to have clinical relevance.
So we started with the protein BTK, and this was in
part because in the early days of drug discovery, nobody really understood whether
you could get good
in vitro parameters of a very large or large or small
molecule. So we wanted to have a target that was present in the blood compartment
that would be the most accessible, we thought, to such a new
modality. And BTK is this really
interesting target in that it's not only interesting for oncology
or
eye and eye and even neurology, but it has many,
many dependencies across many cell types, one of which is in the
B cell
when chronic stimulation or constant
activity of the B cell receptor sends signaling down through the protein, a
signaling cascade to the nucleus telling cells to continue to proliferate.
Removal of the function of BTK, either through inhibition or through
degradation, could block that cascade.
The drugs in the clinic have been very transformational.
This is a situation where early treatment of this disease really
revolved around chemotherapy. And now most patients can
begin to be treated with a targeted agent and obtain
responses that are long-lived. But
resistance is still very common in the case of inhibitors, and
nobody really robustly obtains complete responses
in this disease because of that little bit of activity of BTK or
the B cell receptor signaling will allow these cells to continue to
propagate over time.
So we wanted to set out to make a degrader to BTK and try to perfect the properties
of that degrader and then ask this question whether removal of the protein was
really distinct. And so the answer is, I'm going to start with the
answer is very much yes. So this is our latest clinical
data. We released it at ASH at the end of last year, and this is showing our dose
escalation, our Phase 1
A and B. And we're showing a lymph node reduction
across the population of patients.
And there's several things that are very important about this waterfall.
One, obviously, the robust response across almost every single
patient that we treated with doses from 50 all the way up to 600.
But if you look underlying the waterfall plot, you see this very big
complex map of the genetic insults that these patients
carry within their malignant cells.
So they not only have BTK resistance mutations from treatment with
BTK inhibitors, but they have many other very deleterious
changes to their genome that really prevent these cells from controlling
normal response
to signaling of the B cell receptor.
In addition, the highlighted asterisks at the top of
several of the bars along the chart are patients that actually have CNS
disease. So this is a disease that is a component of disease that is
relatively rare in CLL, but typically, if
you encounter CLL disease or CNS disease, you are not
allowed onto trials. You really don't have an effective
treatment that is proven to interact in the brain compartment.
And so there is a very big unmet need for a drug that
not only controls BTK and the B cell receptor signaling pathway, but then
that can actually
occupy many of the privileged compartments of the body.
So if you compare this rate
of response that I was just showing you in the waterfall to the best
inhibitor that is currently on the space.
So pirtobrutinib has
now
obtained approval. That happened at the end of last year.
This is a highly optimized inhibitor that has really incredible safety
and response. But if you compare patients that
have
received many lines of therapy, as we're showing here
for the pirtobrutinib trial,
patients in late-line settings have about a 65% to
69%
ORR, and the duration of response is just a little over a year.
So if you compare that now to what we're observing with our drug,
bexipridil is the name,
in this late-line setting. And actually, you could even consider this slightly
later line because many of the patients that we were treating in our trial actually
failed on pirtobrutinib. We are seeing an 83% response
rate and 20 months so far of duration of response.
So not quite a doubling, but very much meaningful in
terms of how it differentiates from one of the best inhibitors that really has
just been able to prove itself in the clinic.
So we're extremely excited to be able to really
conclude from our test of this head-to-head
comparison, although it's cross-trial.
But I think you appreciate what I mean that in this case
where you can really
focus on the target and what your drug is doing and what an inhibitor versus a
degrader can do, there is a difference.So why is there a difference?
So I'm going to go through just a few of the parameters that we think are
meaningful. And Danette's talk was really beautiful in terms of thinking about some
of the kinetic parameters of how you would optimize a degrader.
But if you think about in terms of how you're going to control the pathway,
inhibition is intended to be a complete
blockade of a protein's function, enzymatic protein function.
But if you really understand your ability to maintain
drug levels throughout the course of treatment in the wild,
even in a patient population, your ability to have enough inhibitor on board
to always control every bit of your enzymatic function of a protein
is pretty much unachievable. And the difference then in terms of
using an agent like a degrader that actually removes that protein and
removes it to a point where there really isn't any protein left to expend
its enzymatic function, it really gives you that very
big differential of what would happen
in the course of trying to pass a signal from the cell surface down
to
the nucleus of the cell.
So one of the other learnings that we obtained in developing our
degrader and truly trying to understand how it differentiate from inhibitors is
that we actually observed that the degrader could cover the
spans of mutation, whether or not we designed against them or not,
in a superior way to inhibitors. And that was a surprise to us, and I think the
field is still trying to internalize what is going to be the resistance
mechanism of degraders. Certainly, there will be a resistance mechanism of
degraders. But one of the very first, very dramatic learnings that
we obtained is that we had very robust activity against
all of the clinical mutations. I'm showing them here at the bottom of this
plot. Whereas the inhibitors all designed to be very effective against one or
two of these
resistance mutations, always had liabilities and often two or three liabilities.
And so this difference is really all about that induced
proximity event, the transience that you have to
obtain by bringing your ligase to your
target of interest, and that the brief duration of that response
allows you to accommodate a lot of affinities to your target of interest.
Therefore, if they change due to mutation, you can still affect a brief
ternary complex and still affect removal of the protein.
And so this is a fundamental learning of this field that I think is really
important for people to appreciate.
The other piece that is important to think about when you think about, well, why
does that work? We did use a binder that actually sat right in the active site
pocket of BTK. And I'm showing you here our binder in blue, and I'm
illustrating in red the amino acids that mutate in this
pocket and yield a dead kinase. And in green,
the amino acids that mutate and leave that kinase active.
And so luckily in our design, and I think it was partly by design and
partly by luck, we were able to choose a binder that really didn't interact with
any of the side chains of these amino acids that would really distort the pocket
and change the activity of this protein.
So even if you choose a binder very adjacent to
surfaces of the protein that could change through mutation in
response to drug treatment, it doesn't preclude you from being able to create a
degrader that still is very effective in that setting.
One of the next learnings that we had, and this isn't a rate constant as Danette
was really telling us about, but we really wanted to understand how much drug do
we need in a cell or in a body to be able to affect this induced proximity.
So the goal of making degraders is to be able to work
substoichiometrically. What you're wanting to do is be able to have
these transient interactions with proteins and not have to occupy
your cell or your patient with more drug in molecule count than
the proteins that that drug is trying to interact with.
And so what I'm showing you here is the Cmax
and the Cmin in free levels, and I'm comparing that.
I'm using one of our effective clinical doses at 200 mgs
QD, and I'm comparing that steady state rate to the amount of drug you would
need to be effective with ibrutinib or zanubrutinib or even
pirtobrutinib. And what you see is this very large difference,
particularly to the non-covalent agents, of how much drug actually
really needs to be dosed and maintained to be able to fully cover the
activity of the target. And that
amount of drug that is effective is really a translation of how
efficient this drug is. So on the right, you see a different
version, not exactly the rate calculation that Danette showed you, but
it was a calculation derived to understand how many protein molecules
in an hour you could degrade with any one molecule of degrader.
And so in our dose range, our effective dose range, we're degrading about 10,000
protein molecules per hour.
So how does that translate into the dose we use?
So this is a piece that kind of takes people a little bit to think about.
Our approved
dose to go forward into our registrational trials is 600 milligrams, and it seems
actually a bit larger than you might expect if you're trying to dose
substoichiometrically. But as most of us realize, most of these bifunctional
molecules do not have the best bioavailability.
And so you're usually fighting your formulation or your
bioavailability to obtain a drug on board.
But what I'm showing you here is a steady state PK profile of 600 milligrams, and
you're seeing that it is below
one
nanomolar. And what that means is it's well below the 500 nanomolar that you need
for pirto. It's still very low. But we're dosing at a level that we
can go much above the wild type DC95 coverage.
So we can dose to cover all of the different potencies that
we've observed against the different mutations that are in our clinical population.
And what does that mean? When we did our Project Optimist dose optimization,
we compared between 200 milligrams and 600 milligrams
in a randomized study, and we could clearly see the difference of progression-free
survival when dosing at 600 because we really were obtaining a dose
that would cover the full extent of the mutations that we were seeing in our very
complex patient population.So does that higher dose,
does it equate to less safety? So this is another extremely
important parameter in this field, and there still is quite a bit of this
understanding of how a degrader-induced proximity drugs might translate
into safety. And I think it's even more relevant in the context of
induced proximity, but we're talking about degraders here.
So what I'm showing you here are the treatment
emergent adverse events for either all doses on the
left or at 600 milligrams on the right.
And what you see actually is, if you look very closely,
the profile of the 600 milligram dose is really no different than the profile
of all of the doses together, meaning as you dose higher, you don't see a higher
rate of adverse events.
So if you look at it another way, if you look at the exposure response analysis, so
this is a preliminary exposure response analysis, where we really have looked at
all of the BK over the course of all of our patient dosing and
related it to the probability of an event that is on
the x-axis. And what you see in the middle of this graph is this little light
yellow line, not very dark, but it's representing our 600 milligram
exposure level here, just shown in AUC.
And the big line in black, the 10X range that's
showing from an efficacious dose of 200 milligrams all the way
up to tenfold above that, we really don't see much deviation at
all in that rate of probability of an adverse event.
And so that is the definition of a wide therapeutic index drug.
So this is really fascinating to know that degraders, these very complex,
big molecules that are interacting and bringing proteins together in
a way that they normally don't, are not really causing anything that really is
changing the safety or biology of our patient population, which is an
elderly population that is relatively frail, a population that should
expose safety concerns if they were to be there, certainly at
the doses that we're using. So really exciting to understand that degraders can
achieve a profile that might be more akin to antibodies.
What else did we learn in our clinical practice with this drug?
We have also learned that there really is no association of degraders with QT
prolongation. So this is a parameter that is really
something that is being keyed off by a lot of safety
groups as well as
academic and the FDA as well. Many
of the early degraders had a QT prolongation as an early
observation, and people began to think, well, is it part of the mechanism?
Is it something driven by this act of trying to force proteins through the
proteasome? And we did a very thorough study, as we've done with
this program and many other programs.
And if you look at the rate of
QT prolongation in healthy volunteers, which I'm showing you here, or in
patients or in pre-clinical models, which we also did, we absolutely see
no
QT prolongation on treatment of the drug.
And actually, the
curve that I'm showing you here is a profile that is acceptable even to
use outside of oncology. So quite
distinct. So why is that? Why were we able to obtain this profile?
Why are other degraders not always seeing this profile?
Of course, there's myriad reasons. Every drug has their own parameters.
But one of the reasons is selectivity.
So we have spent quite a bit of time understanding the selectivity of
all of our degraders. I think that's a fundamental piece of optimizing your
degrader. And what's really freeing in the case of targeted protein degradation is
you actually have a tool that can give you a broader view of selectivity than has
been available for most other modalities, particularly inhibitors.
Looking at the entirety of the proteome that you can sample in whatever cell type
you look at is far more effective than looking at a kinome scan.
So here I'm showing you the profile of vexbrotidig, and this is used at
10xDC90. We test over the course of 24 hours, and we are
measuring over 8,000 proteins, pretty much as thorough
of a
depth of sampling that you can get in a primary cell line.
So we always use human PBMCs for this particular analysis, and we
actually even sample across a population of individuals as we're collecting
this data. So we compare vexbrotidig to two
of the other BTK inhibitors that are in the clinic.
And what you see is there is a very different profile between degraders.
Each degrader has their own
properties as it comes to being able to form very exclusively one ternate
complex versus others. And some of the off targets that you see in these
profiles can absolutely have a possibility of influencing
the safety of those drugs. So just a
couple more points that I want to make before I close.
One of the other things that we've been looking at from the very beginning of the
study is the
sequence data from
blood cells pulled from our patients over periods of time.
We were looking for the mutations that might cause escape of the drug or
looking to see what is happening with the profile of the existing mutations
in the population. And I'm showing you three case studies here
at baseline, really assessing the diversity of mutations
these patients are bringing to the
problem. And what you see in that very first patient is many different
BTK and PLC gamma mutations, as well as
P53
and
other mutations that maybe don't have quite as much clarity in
their ability to predict good or bad response, but they're
all things that get tracked and tried to be interpreted
as people are trying to understand the likelihood of response.
And what you see after half a year of treatment, that's cycle seven,
day one, roughly, and then at about a year, cycle
13, as we're showing you here. Slowly over time, as we are
treating these patients and clearing the disease burden,
we're not just clearing those malignant clones that have BTK mutations.
We are actually clearing clones that have P53 mutations.
So this is something that's been observed subtly in some of the
studies that have gone on. But typically, in the course of a year,
another BTK mutation will pop up when you're looking at these profiles from
inhibitors. And so what we're seeing very clearly is this progression
of removal of the clones that have these underlying mutations
that are leading to the malignant growth of the cells and
no emergence of new BTK mutations.So the
last vignette I want to show you is just the example of the clinical
profile of one of our very first treated patients, a
71-year-old female who was diagnosed in 2014.
She had quite a number of years of successful treatment.
She started with an aggressive treatment of chemoimmunotherapy
and then moved on to a combo of ibrutinib and
venetoclax. Her disease was well-controlled for many years, but then, of
course, she progressed as all patients typically do with CLL.
And so she started in our early trial at 50 milligrams.
And I will then just move on to the graph.
So this is a graph of her
absolute lymphocyte count profile.
So when you very
thoroughly contain the B-cell receptor signaling pathway, what you
do is you liberate these cells from the lymph node or the spleen or
the organs that they have been
transient in, and you send them out into the bloodstream.
And so you see this big release of absolute lymphocytes
into the bloodstream. But almost immediately, within eight weeks, this patient
was
assessed as having a partial response, and that was because of the decrease
in size of her hematopoietic organs.
And that response continued to deepen over time, and this is something that we see
in almost all of our patients. And so by about a year, she
was feeling well enough that she wanted to really understand whether or not
her disease was controlled. And so the only way to be assessed with a
complete response in CLL is to have a bone marrow biopsy.
And so this is actually a kind of
invasive procedure, and many patients don't want to undergo it unless they really
feel like they have achieved something substantial in their disease.
And so rather than escalate from our very lowest dose of 50 milligrams,
she did a bone marrow biopsy to understand whether she had residual disease.
And there was some residual disease seen slightly after
a year. So she dose escalated. But again, she was feeling so well and
her disease was so controlled, she only escalated to 100.
And this was a point where we already knew that the higher doses for us were really
effective.
And so after then, many other cycles of
dosing at 100, we reassessed bone marrow, and she achieved complete
response and is in complete response now.
So very satisfying to really know the dose response, the response
to disease control, but ultimately to complete
response. I think that is
the objective of this project, and I think this is a very satisfying result.
So just to end with the fact that we are so confident of this drug, we are
going forward into our Phase 3 pivotal study, and we're going
head-to-head against Perto, the most recently approved drug.
And we're really hopeful for the outcome of our first clinical
degrader. Thank you.
Frankly, from which Uptech, great molecule- ...
over this first protect you approve in cancer.
So, but from your dosage, 600 milligrams.
So what's your in vitro data, DC50, Dmax?
Because that seems like your compound not that
potent from in vitro IC. But you did great
Dmax and no tox almost like, right?
Compared to all the other protect. What's the reason?
Yeah, sorry. I didn't show any of the vitro data just for time, but we have
picomolar potency in vitro in primary
cells or in
cancered cell lines like TMD8. And the Dmax
is near complete with this molecule.
So the dosage that high is because poor PK?
It's
bioavailability, right? And different formulations, actually-
Sure
... give us much lower doses. So
the amount that you would use if you used advanced formulation could
be one-tenth of that actually, depending on the formulation.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay, quick question.
Yeah. Quick question. So really exciting to see the phenomena outcome in the
clinical trials. And we're really encouraged to see that we can overcome many
of the resistance from the inhibitors.
Just wondering, during the clinical trials, have you ever observed any
obtained resistance to
your BTK degraders due to any mechanisms like
mutations or loss of functions or anything?
Yeah. So there is one mutation that has now been described
in publication, and we have several abstracts on
this and about ready to publish a paper on an A428D
mutation. So this is a mutation within the C spine of the BTK
protein, and it actually collapses a bit the active site
pocket, and no inhibitor or degrader can bind to
BTK in the context of that mutation. So that is a very deleterious mutation.
It forces the protein into a full scaffold function.
And interestingly, in vitro, that protein is not as
robust. So it's very difficult to maintain that mutation in culture
and study it. So ultimately, if you take away a BTK-targeted
agent, it actually disappears in the patient population.
So most of
our work
has been focused on can you try combos of BTK agents, or
can you look at other non-BTK targeted agents in
interval therapy to basically
allow
treatment of that mutation?
But no change observed on the UTR ligase side after
the prolonged treatment?
Yeah, we haven't observed any decrease
in cereblon expression that led to any loss of ability
to degrade the protein. But I think there were a poster or two
at this conference where people have been trying to study that in vitro in other
cell lines. So no doubt there could be upregulation of pathways
that are parallel to the B-cell receptor pathway, and
there could be
other mutations that we have not seen in the clinic, certainly.
Thank you. Thanks very much, Gwen Hansen. You can sit here again.
And now it's a pleasure to introduce Sherry Ao.
She's a NextGen Star awardee, and she'll be talking
about first-in-class dual AR/Arv7 molecular glue degraders.
Okay.
Thank you, Michelle.
Good morning, everyone. Thank you for the
opportunity for me to present here and
excited to share our work with you today.
And this is my disclosure.
As everyone here may be aware, prostate cancer remains a
major clinical challenge, and the androgen receptor continuously
continues to be a dominant therapeutic target in the disease.
So currently, about 90% of prostate cancer
therapeutics target the androgen receptor through its ligand
binding domain.
However, one of the major clinical challenge we face
is the rapid onset of treatment resistant.
Clinically, several
resistant mechanism has been well validated,
including AR amplification, AR ligand binding
mutation, and the expression of AR splice
variant. And today, I will be focusing specifically
on AR splice variant expression.
So in here, among the AR splice variant, Arv7 is
the most prevalent. It is constitutively active in the
nucleus and drives tumor growth even in the absence of hormones.
So Arv7 is detected in approximately
75% of CRPC patients. And when we
look at the protein structure here, Arv7,
it lacks the C-terminal ligand binding and the hinge
domains, which make it resistant to a standard of care of
treatments such as AR inhibitors like
abiraterone and enzalutamide, and also taxane, which
is the only FDA-approved chemotherapy for prostate cancer.
So as a result, patients with CRPC will
express this Arv7 currently have no effective
treatment option.
And in clinically, Arv7 expression driving
resistant to AR signaling inhibitor and taxane
chemotherapy is associated with shorter
progression-free and overall survival.
And currently, there have no pharmacological inhibitors of
Arv7 exist, making its inhibition an
urgent and clinical unmet need in prostate cancer.
So for us, what we identified a small molecule that
specific inhibitor inhibits Arv7.
What we do here is we develop a robust, high-throughput screen
using an enzyme fragment complementation assay
with the Arv7 activities and nuclear
localization as the read out. So this assay
has a high Z score of 0.8, meaning that it
provide excellent separation of the signal and the
noise. So briefly, if you see here, we have a stable
cell line express the Arv7 tag donor,
and also we have an acceptor in the nucleus.
So every time when the Arv7 translocated to the
nucleus, the luminescent signal will be turning on.
So a compound that inhibits Arv7 will reduce
the signal, and this we will consider as a positive hit.
And in the primary screen of
170,000 compound library, followed by a
dose titration confirmation and counter cell screen
assay, and a secondary GFP-based assay.
From there, we identify 13
compounds that effective suppress Arv7 expression.
Now, interestingly, this hit represent a unique
chemotype distinct from all known AR moderators,
providing a novel starting point for therapeutic development.
Now from our high-throughput screen, we identify 13 hits
compound, and we select this number 7907 as our top
candidate, as it inhibits both Arv7 and
AR full-length in prostate cancer with endogenously
expression of both.
To determine its mechanism of action, we first confirm
this candidate does not affect mRNA
expression of Arv7 and AR full-length, but it
rather destabilize them at a protein level,
shorten their half-life by approximately three times,
suggesting that degradation. And to determine whether
this involves proteasome degradation, what we do, we co-treat
the cell with the proteasome inhibitor MG132.
While the 7907 alone reduce the
Arv7 level here, this effect is reversed
by MG132, supporting a proteasome-dependent
degradation mechanism.
We then perform a hit to leads optimization by medicinal chemistry
and structure activities relationship study to improve
potency. So we generate over 60 analog
with different modification sites, R1, R2, R3,
R4, and R5, and we use a cell line expressing
Arv7 and AR full-length to test the analog with the different
modification in a dose titration experiment, and the
EC50 was measured.And then we then ran
the EC50 of all the active analog based on the
activities on ARV7 protein expression.
We observed that analog number 15 and 64
had enhanced potency in ARV7 expression,
as well as they exhibit a good
drug-likeness score. And therefore, these
two compound was considered as our dual AR full-length
ARV7 lead candidate, and they will be using for
further experimental investigation.
And next, we established a C4-2
CRPC cell engineered to stably express ARL
luciferase reporter and dox-inducible
EGFP-AR full length or ARV7.
Now, using this cell system, we did a time course
experiment and confirmed that this number 15 was
degraded both ARV7 and full-length within the four
hour of treatment. And under this same condition,
we assess ARL
luciferase activities and show that our
active compound, like number 15 or 64,
suppress transcriptionally activity driven by both
either ligand-binding
AR and ARV7, but the inactive
analog number 48 had no effect, and
ARV110 suppress AR-driven transcript
only, but without affecting the ARV7
here.
Now, we know that ARV7 is a key driver of
enzalutamide resistant, which is standard of care in
mCRPC. So our lead compound number 15 was
able to overcome enzalutamide resistant
in
LNCaP 95 cell that carries AR ligand binding
mutation and express both ARV7 and AR
full-length, consistent with its degradation activity
showing here. And importantly, it show
no activities against normal prostate epithelial
cell RWPE-1.
Both this compound number 15, 64 has
similar activities in LNCaP 95 cell and were
superior to both enzalutamide and
ARV110.
And to quantify AR pathway activities, we
treat the 22RV1 cell with our lead compound.
We have ARV110, enzalutamide, and inactive analog
with number 48 and perform RNA Seq followed by analysis
with Dr. Xuanrun Chen in Dr. Barbari's lab at
Weill Cornell. So what we did here, we first calculate an
AR score based on the 21 established
AR target genes. So as you see here at one
micromolar, both number 15 or number
64 at one micromolar, red or blue
dot showing here, significantly down-regulate AR
transcriptional signature compared to a vehicle.
And ARV110 showing here also
down-regulate AR transcriptional signature at the same
concentration, while the number 48 or
enzalutamide showing here had no effect.
The heat map show consistent downregulation across
individual AR target genes. The key genes such as
KLK3, FKBP5, TMPRSS2 are
strongly suppressed, confirm the robust inhibition
of AR signaling. Now, to validate this
independently, what we do, we also analyze our data
using published 22RV1 RNA Seq and ChIP Seq data set from
molecular cell. And from this data set, they have
been identified 341 AR active genes and
475 ARV7 activated genes. And
using this, what we observed is consistent suppression of both
AR and ARV7 transcriptional program by number
15 or 64, showing here and
here, and indicate that effective dual
inhibition.
Now, next, we
evaluate our lead compound in vivo using 22RV1
xenograft and enzalutamide-resistant model express both
ARV7 and full-length AR. So first, we
have cell were implant subcutaneously
into the castration male mice. And once tumor
reach approximately 100 cubic millimeters, we administer
a daily oral dosing of our lead compound with
ARV110 as our comparator. So as
you can see here in the red line, both number 15 and
64 significantly inhibits tumor growth,
outperform enzalutamide, and showing superior
efficacy to ARV110. And importantly,
the analysis of the tumor confirmed that this number 15
effectively degrade both AR and ARV7 compared with the
vehicle control, demonstrate our on-target activities in
vivo. And as expected, the AR pro drug
degrade only AR without affecting ARV7.
Similar result we have observed with the other candidate, number 64.
Now, next, we tested the BID PO
administration once since because our PK
data show a half-life of approximately four to five
hours. So we have included
AR-V766 as an additional
comparator in this experiment. This is a drug, a next generation
AR pro drug currently in clinical development.
So under this condition,
you can see that 64 have shown a stronger
tumor growth inhibition with a nearly flat growth curve
here. So overall, both compound were
well-tolerated with no significant weight loss or
toxicity.Now another key
question is where our lead compound binds.
So to address this, what we did is we generate an AR and
ARV7 deletion mutant encoding different functional
domain, both either those shared between the isoform or
those unique to each other.
So and then we transfect them into the C42 cell.
This allow us to mapping the lead compound activities to
specific domain within the AR protein.
Now, using ARV7 and AR full-length as our
control, consistent with our finding, compound 15
here had no activities against both protein,
and interestingly, they have no activities against any of domain
except the N-terminal domain. Now, we further
generate the ARV7 and full-length deletion mutant
encoding different functional subdomain within the N-terminal
domain, and you can see AF1 and TAL1 mediate the
activities of compound 15 but not the TAL5
region. And this is particular significant because no
AR N-terminal domain compound that target
TAL1 currently existed, highlighting the
novelty of our mechanism.
And to further understand the mechanism, we confirmed that compound number
15 induced proteasome degradation of both AR and
ARV7. Next, we ask which E3 ubiquitin
ligase mediate these activities.
Now, there are three major classes of
ubiquitin ligases, is Cullin-RING, HECT and
RB/RLC family. And using those
two compound, we find that inhibition of HECT
ligase with heclin did not affect degradation,
but inhibition of Cullin-RING ligase with
MLN4924 blocked the compound number 15
activities. And this indicate the involvement of this
pathway.
Now, the Cullin-RING E3 ligase family includes over 600
members, and to pinpoint the specific ligase engaged by
our lead compound, we have performed a CRISPR-based E3
ligase screen, which carried out by a talented scientist on our
team, Dr. Michelle Naidoo. And if you have a chance to stop by
her late-breaking abstract poster yesterday, you may already
seen some of this exciting work.
And here, I will highlighted some key finding from this
screen. As expected, selebron was
identified as the top E3 ligase hit for the
AR-V766. This is used to validating the
performance of the screen. And in contrast,
our preliminary CRISPR results suggest that
DDB1, along with other components of Cullin-RING
complex, such as RBX1, are involved in
mediating AR and ARV7 degradation by our lead
compound.
And to validate this, we perform a DDB1 knockout
experiment, and DDB1 knockout partially reverse
ARV7 degradation, confirming its role in mediate the
activities of our lead compound.
In summary, our compound demonstrate several key
advantage. This induced dual
degradation of both ARV7 and full-length AR
in single treatment through a unique chemotype
distinct from existing AR targeting agent, regardless
of the binding site. They engage two of the
AR N-terminal domain, specifically the TAL1 and AF1
region, overcome the enzalutamide resistance in both in
vitro and in vivo model, and are oral
bioavailable with no observed
toxicity as an effective anti-tumor doses.
Mechanistically, so they function as a molecular
glue-like manner, and we are currently elucidate the
associated E3 ligase complex.
And overall, this approach has the potential to benefit
patient with mCRPC, as well as those with
hormone-sensitive disease while delay the ARV7-driven
resistance.
And lastly, I would like to thank my mentor, all the people and collaborator
involved in this project. And in addition, I would like to acknowledge
all the funding support. Thank you for listening, and I'm happy to take any
questions.
Okay. Thank you very much, Sherry. We have time for a couple questions.
Okay. Thank you for the talk. I have two questions.
First is about the target engagement.
Do you have any data to confirm your molecule is actually binding
to AR and ARV7?
So
we have functional mapping to the N-terminal
and SISA data showing thermal stability
of the both ARV7 and AR full-length, supporting
the target engagement, and currently we have purified the
ARV7 and are validating the direct binding using the
SPR in vitro binding assay.
Okay. Thank you. The second question is about the specificity.
Did you do any proteomics study to confirm it's
specifically degrading AR and ARV7 but not any other
proteins?
That's a great question. So we have been performing a global
proteomics showing AR and ARV7 among the top
1% of most down-regulated protein.
These proteomics cover entire proteome, and we see a
few others, but they are consistent with some downstream
effect because we did this experiment in twenty-four
hours, and currently we are validate this in early time point
to elucidate the exact off-target effects.
Thank you.
Thank you. Any other questions for
Sherry?Okay. If not,
let's thank Sherry again.
Thank you so much.
And congratulations on your award.
Great.
So thank you, everybody. Now it's my turn.
I'm Michelle Arkin, professor of pharmaceutical chemistry at UCSF,
and I'm going to talk about molecular glues for native protein-protein
interactions.
That's my disclosures.
So biology is really complicated, and it would be
really nice if we could use
genetics to really understand how these protein interaction networks work,
but I want to show you some of the limitations there.
So say in this interaction network map, we wanted to understand the function of
this protein, this gene name. If we knocked out that
protein, what would we really learn about the cells?
Because that protein is engaged in transcriptional regulation with the
Myc in the top left corner there, signal transduction, EGF receptor in the
bottom left-hand corner, nutrient sensing with mTOR at the bottom
right, DNA repair with some proteins up
there in the top right.
So
what we really want to do is understand how proteins interact with each other,
and the best way to do that is to map the protein-protein interactions.
And if we can modulate those protein-protein interactions in a specific way, we
could really understand the function of these hub or node proteins that are
engaged in a lot of different biology.
So here, instead of altering the function of the
node or the protein, we want to
modulate the function of the edge, the interaction between those
two. And you could argue that the most specific way to do that is by gluing
them together with a molecular glue.
We can take advantage of both sides of that protein to get really
selective, specific, prospective modulation of that
interaction.
So that's what I want to talk about, and that protein happens to be the beta
isoform of 14.3.3. There are seven isoforms, and this is just one
of those isoforms, but they're very highly overlapping in function.
And in fact, most of them heterodimerize with each other.
So the approach we want to take is a molecular glue approach because we want to
take advantage of that native protein-protein interaction and essentially
stabilize it, lock it in, turn up the gain, turn up the
rheostat on the function of that protein-protein interaction.
And if we understand what that interaction does already, then we should be able to
predict what it's going to do pharmacologically.
And if we don't know what it does pharmacologically, then we'll be able to deduce
it by seeing the effect of stabilizing it.
14.3.3, the protein that we're going to talk about today, is a phospho binding
chaperone. So it's this beautiful W-shaped alpha helical dimeric
protein along the
axis there, is the dimer interface.
And this protein binds to hundreds, maybe thousands of
phosphorylated sites in the proteome.
If you study kinases, you study 14.3.3 because that is the major
effector of protein phosphorylation in the cell.
And this is an example of a crystal structure of a
natural product called fusicoccine in orange, stabilizing the native interaction
between 14.3.3 and a plant ion channel.
And when it stabilizes this native interaction, it augments the function of that
interaction, which is to traffic the protein to the membrane, and then it's
hyper turned on. That's bad for the plant, kills the plant, and then the
fungus that produces that natural product, fusicoccine, can eat the dead plant.
So my colleague Christian Ottman realized years ago
that it happens in plants, but I bet we can use it for human
biology as well. And so over the last several years,
he's developed crystal structures and programs for dozens of
14.3.3 protein interaction targets.
And the targets of 14.3.3 are a veritable rogue's gallery of
disease-related proteins, many important and currently undruggable
targets in cancer, such as transcription factors, the high
specificity for different proteins that are actually well-known, like
RAS kinases, RAF kinases, which I'll talk about.
So in all of these different systems, we can try to
develop small molecules that, like fusicoccine, glue those
proteins together in a highly selective way by taking advantage of both
sides of that protein interface. And so I'm just going to talk about one here,
about cRAF.
So cRAF also gives you, all the RAF kinases give you a good example of how
14.3.3 works and why it's kind of complicated to explain to give an
elevator pitch on 14.3.3. So it's shown in gray
as this dimeric protein. These are cartoons based on cryo-EM structures that
have come out over the last several years, including very recently, cRAF.
Most of the data is actually on BRAF.
So 14.3.3, is it an activator or an inhibitor?
Well, it depends on the phosphorylation state of cRAF.
When cRAF is phosphorylated at this N-terminal-ish site,
259, and the C-terminal site, 621,
14.3.3, one dimer of 14.3.3 holds one monomer of RAF
kinase in an inactive conformation.
When the site near the N-terminus is dephosphorylated,
the protein can open up, bind to the membrane, bind to RAS,
then the fully active form of RAFS are h**o or
heterodimers bound to RAS and bound to one dimer of
14.3.3. So now 14.3.3 is stabilizing the
active dimer form,
one dimer of 14.3.3 binding to a dimer of RAF kinases.
Okay, so it's both an inhibitor and an activator, context dependent.
So what if we could stabilize just that inhibitory side
and knock down MAP kinase signaling by stabilizing this
negative regulatory interaction? So that's what we set out to do.
So one more important point about 14.3.3 sites and
trying to make molecular glues that stabilize specific protein
complexes1433 binds to linear
intrinsically disordered regions of proteins that are phosphorylated at
a serine or threonine. Other than that, there's a weak logo.
You can sort of recognize it looks like a PKA, PKC, or AKT
site, but a very
broad selectivity profile besides that
phosphorylation site.
So here in this cryo-EM structure,
we have CRAF here with the ADP bound
MET kinase, which comes along for the ride. Here's 1433.
This is the C-terminal site, and this is the N-terminal
phosphorylation site. Now you'll notice there's no density on
either side of that phosphorylation site.
So the protein is intrinsically disordered region of protein.
On either side of the 1433 site, it's intrinsically disordered.
We can't discern it in the cryo-EM map.
But at the site that's bound to 1433, it's highly structured.
So this gives us a general way of thinking about how to
modulate intrinsically disordered proteins by stabilizing their
protein-protein interactions, which are ordered and structured.
The other important point about this, because they're intrinsically disordered
structures, phosphopeptides, much easier to work with than
conditionally phosphorylated intrinsically disordered full-length proteins.
Phosphopeptides mimic the conformation, the shape, the
binding of the full-length protein.
So here you can see overlaps from the cryo-EM structure in dark blue
and a crystal structure in light blue of CRAF bound to 1433
in gray.
So we will use for biochemical assays, I may or may not say it crisply,
but for biochemical assays, we will be using the phosphopeptides, and then
in cells, we'll use full-length proteins.
So we're going to make a molecular glue that binds to that inhibitory site,
locks it down in the inhibited state, leaves the
constitutive site or the C-terminal site alone.
So the way we're going to do that is a technology called disulfide trapping or
disulfide tethering, and the basic concept is that we have
1433 in gray bound to CRAF in blue,
and one isoform of 1433, the sigma isoform, has a cysteine
residue positioned close to the end of that peptide, and that's
actually the fusococcin binding site.
So that gives us inspiration for how we might use covalency or reversible
covalency targeting that cysteine residue to bind to this new
composite surface formed by CRAF and 1433.
So we can do that experiment. We do a readout either by
fluorescence anisotropy or by mass spectrometry.
And in the mass spectrometry experiment, we do the experiment looking for
molecules that have disulfides that can bind to that cysteine
residue. We do that under conditions that allow us to distinguish chemical
reactivity from molecular recognition.
So in this experiment, we only identify molecules that bind to that binding site,
recognize that binding site, and also can make the disulfide bond.
So it's site-directed, but also measuring binding.
So we do the experiment this way with 1433.
Then we do it again in the presence of a phosphopeptide, and we look for
those molecules that bind preferentially in the presence of the
phosphopeptide over its absence.
So here's an example of the estrogen receptor and CRAF, just two examples
from many that are in this paper.
Here at the bottom, so you can see how different these two
structures are. So if you're a molecule looking at
that binding site, the estrogen receptor binding site looks very
different. The size, shape, what amino acids are pointing into that
pocket versus the CRAF site.
And in fact, we see most compounds are selective for one
or the other. So in these plots, each
compound is a dot. Along the x-axis, we have the amount that
they're bound in the absence of a phosphopeptide.
So this compound, for example, binds very well to 1433 but is
displaced by CRAF.
This is a neutral quadrant, and this is the potentially cooperative quadrant or
molecular glue quadrant, where this protein binds to the
compound well in the presence of CRAF, but very poorly in the absence of
CRAF. So we see a few different things in this cooperative
quadrant. Some
phosphopeptides pick up many more stabilizing hits than other
phosphopeptides. Some of these are common structures that show up
in
two or more
molecular glue screens, and others show up only
in one. So each target has specific and less
specific molecular glues.
So the way we characterize these, we can start with the mass spectrometry
experiment. As I mentioned, we want compounds that bind poorly to 1433 in
the absence of any peptide. Otherwise, they'll just get sopped up by all the
1433. It's a highly abundant protein.
Instead, we want those compounds to bind very strongly in the presence of the
phosphopeptide. So this gives us an apparent binding affinity.
We can then turn it around and say, well, what is the fluorescence polarization?
What is the degree of stabilization of the protein peptide
complex? And here the compound doesn't bind to the
peptide by itself. But when 1433 is present, as we titrate
in compound, we see an increase in anisotropy, indicating a
stabilization of that protein complex.
That gives us an EC50 for the molecule.
And then looking at doing the experiment yet another way, we can get the
apparent binding affinity for the protein-protein interaction.
Here it's about 10 micromolar in the absence of compound, and then
subnanomolar in the presence of compound.
So we can get very significant fold stabilization.
And I think for time I didn't include it, but using SPR, we can
get on rates and off rates and show that we're increasing the on rate by
10s to 30-fold, and we're decreasing the off rate by 30 to 100
fold.So the compound EC50s are in the low
micromolar range, but the effectiveness of those compounds at that
range is to stabilize the protein-protein interaction by 1,000-fold.
Okay, so with a small amount of compound, you can affect a very high
degree of protein complex formation.
Here's a crystal structure of what that compound looks like.
If I showed you the
CRAF peptide in a space filling model, you would hardly be able to see the compound
at all. Just a little bromine would stick up here.
So this compound is very intimately bound in this new protein
interaction site at the interface, like a piece of two-sided tape
contacting both the 1433 and the CRAF.
When you're really making good contacts with the partner protein, even though
1433 is common on all of these, you can see high selectivity.
This is an experiment using 80 different phosphopeptides with highly different
sequences and structures. And the dotted line, which you may or may not be
able to see, about here,
is the line for statistically significant stabilization at a high
concentration of compound. And really only one target
comes above that when we do dose responses that's significantly stabilized.
And we actually launched a new program around the APIN task because they're
excellent cancer targets.
So we have high selectivity when we target the composite surface on both
sides of the protein, both proteins at that composite surface.
So now what do we expect to see in cells? So here's that pathway again.
So if we stabilize this interaction, we would expect to see an increase in the
protein-protein interaction, which we do using a NanoBRET assay.
We would expect to see more of that phosphorylation sites.
We're inhibiting dephosphorylation by stabilizing that protein
complex. We can see that by western blot.
We would then expect to block downstream effects, such as interaction
with RAS. We also can block interaction with other RAF
kinases, and then blockade of the pathway by a
phospho-ERK inhibition. And in this assay, we inhibit the pathway about as
well as a RAF inhibitor or as trametinib, a MEK
inhibitor.
So one question that you may ask is, "Okay, this is a nice regulatory
interaction. I'm buying the biophysics, but is it going to
be enough? Does it going to have enough juice to just stabilize that
interaction in the case where you have upregulation of the MAP
kinase cascade in cancer?" You have massive upregulation,
massive growth of cells through this pathway, complex
feedback loops. And this is hard even for
really potent inhibitors like trametinib to be effective.
So we thought about where else is the MAP kinase pathway important
in disease biology, and one area is in
RASopathies. Most common RASopathy is Noonan syndrome.
These are developmental disorders where the RAS pathway or the
MAP kinase pathway is slightly upregulated.
So there's a growth advantage to certain cells during development.
They lead to a set of different
issues during organ development, depending on the
RASopathy. But the point
biochemically is that we have a slight upregulation of this pathway.
So rather than a tsunami, like we have in cancer, we just have a little too
much. We need a better dam to hold back that pathway.
So we reasoned that if we stabilize this
interaction, this is really the bottom of the pathway.
All of the mutations in Noonan syndrome, there are 10 different proteins that are
mutated in Noonan syndrome, that we're capturing this flux at
the bottom of the pathway. So since we're at the bottom of the pathway, all of the
mutations should be treatable with this approach.
And you can see there are several different proteins, probably some of your
favorite MAP kinase proteins. 50% of the mutations are in
SHP2 to upregulate the pathway, and 8% are in CRAF
itself.
So these mutations in CRAF, guess where they are?
You're right. They're at the binding site, a 259 binding site
of 1433. So this is a major regulatory node for
CRAF, and therefore, to get over this regulation and upregulate the
pathway, the
proteins are mutated at this site.
And these disease mutations are all fairly rare.
This is the most common, and they're the most highly
correlated with cardiomyopathy, which you could argue is the worst
life-limiting effect of Noonan syndrome.
So we asked, okay, if you have mutations here,
why does that lead to pathway activity?
And it's a combination both of binding affinity, so we have a lower binding
affinity, and because of that lower binding affinity, there's
more dephosphorylation by SHOC2 kinase, less
phosphorylation, less protection by 1433.
So what that leads to is an inhibition of the protein-protein
interaction and an increase in the pathway activity.
So with our molecular glues that bind right here, we can pull that pathway
down back about as well. This is using phospho-ERK again.
SHOC2 mutations hyperactivate the phosphatase.
We can block that about as well as trametinib.
And then two mutations in CRAF itself, high pathway activity,
we can block it about as well again, as trametinib does.
So in short, our goal is to systematically identify protein-protein
interaction stabilizers,
stabilizing native protein complexes.
We can do this selectively because we're binding to a composite surface, and that
composite surface is unique or at least highly unusual, even
though the two proteins
may be very common proteins.
We're using this to modulate undruggable targets and mutated protein-protein
interactions, like inLike with Noonan
syndrome, and extending to new protein-protein interaction networks to
see what we've learned, how that can be translated to other networks.
So I just want to thank the project team that we work with, Christian
Almond, the guru of 1433 chemical biology, Luke
Brunsveld, Jeff Neitz, and Adam Renslo, all medicinal
chemistry colleagues.
Project team members, the ones in blue, have done most of the work that I
described. Our women-powered project team.
Markella Constantinou made all the compounds.
Marloes did all the crystallography.
Johanna Virta, a recently finished graduate student now at Promega,
did the cell biology for Noonan syndrome.
And Holly Vickery, now at RevMed, the cell
biology in wild-type
RAF. And so with that, I just want to
thank you for your attention. Thank you for attending the whole session.
I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
So I have a couple minutes.
Okay, good. So just to wrap up, I'm supposed to make
a few words as session chair. I think we've really seen
the... Oh, there's... I'm sorry.
You blended very well. Please, go ahead.
Okay. Thanks for the great talk. I have a question.
Did you
evaluate your compounds in some cancer models, just like KRAS
or NRAS mutant cancer cell lines?
Yes. We have done in some cancer cell lines.
Mm-hmm.
Or usually, we add EGF to an EGF receptor
cancer cell line, or we overexpress
NRAS mutations, and it works in those cases.
KRAS overexpression is a little complicated, and it's harder for us to measure.
I think the best way to go into that is really to take that into animals.
Okay.
But we haven't done that yet. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you. Thanks so much.
Okay. Well, I think I'll just wrap up the session by saying
thank you everybody. I think our speakers were great.
Thank the first three speakers again.
I think we really see from those three talks a maturation of the field
from cool tricks to real
serious pharmacology, and the future is very bright for
degraders and non-degrader molecular glues.
I'm excited to see all of you helping patients in the near future.
So thank you very much.